so this is something i didn't end up
having time for earlier this week but i
did want to get to it because it's a
preview of what we can expect next week
in the vice presidential debate between
kamala harris and vice president mike
pence when the trump tax story broke
we learned thanks to the new york times
that trump paid no federal taxes in 10
of the last 15 years
paid only 750 total in federal taxes in
2016 and in 2017 but we also learned
about donald trump's debts and we talked
about these earlier in the week
300 million dollars in loans that come
due during what would be trump's second
presidential term if he gets one
420 million dollars in total debt likely
1.1 billion in total debt if you include
other debts and and uh which we outlined
earlier in the week
joe biden's vice presidential nominee
kamala harris
california democratic senator went on
msnbc's lawrence o'donnell program
and pointed out the real threat of trump
owing people money take a look at this
video clip
florence this is why the american people
deserve to have a full accounting
of the financial interest including the
indebtedness
of the president of the united states
and i and i do share in that concern
who does he owe the money to tell us who
do you owe the money to
we need to know that the american people
have a right to know that when the
president of the united states acts
he acts with their priorities in mind
not with his priorities in mind
of course later on this was clarified
including in our segments about it
yesterday
donald trump's debts are a national
security risk we talked about that
now kamala harris was slammed by some
people
because we do know about some of donald
trump's debts
and some of donald trump's debts are to
banks that are household names deutsche
bank
and others those publicly
known and acknowledged debts are not
really the concerning ones those are
often tied to a specific property or a
mortgage and there's
at least relative transparency about
them
the ones that are the big question marks
are the ones that
are from the period 2006 to 2014
and that was a time when donald trump
was spending huge amounts of cash
that he doesn't tend to have as we're
learning
and he spent huge amounts of cash buying
or developing or improving properties
and for a long time there's been a
general question about where the hell
the cash came from
and now with the bombshell new york
times story we only have more questions
about where did the cash come from given
how precarious donald trump's financial
position appears to be
based on the documents that the new york
times obtained when we find out
and as we did previously when we know
that donald trump paid 200 million
dollars in cash
to renovate that turnberry golf course
in scotland
where did 200 million in cash come from
because it doesn't appear that donald
trump had it
and now there is even more skepticism
about it uh trump is claiming hey we
just had 200 million in cash sitting
around but it is extraordinarily
difficult to believe that's the case now
and indeed people who know donald
trump's businesses and his finances have
said
there's no way trump had 200 million in
cash particularly at that time
you can check out adam davidson's work
for the new yorker
as one example of someone who really
understands the finances of trump
and the trump organization and to be
clear we don't
know that these are particularly sketchy
debts
tied to trump's claim of having all this
cash
we just know that at a sort of general
level
it's not believable that trump had this
cash at the time
we don't know where the cash came from
and we know that trump owes a ton of
money so so it's
it's all of those three things put
together now beyond that
not all of trump's deutsche bank debts
are created equal
there are these deutsche bank debts that
like i said are tied to a specific
mortgage to a specific property
but at some point during that same
period
2006 to 2014 donald trump went in the
direction
of private banking at deutsche bank and
at that point the paper trail starts to
get
shadier and shadowier and we just lack
a lot of information about it so there's
sort of a double bottom line here or two
different bottom lines one bottom line
is now with the revelations of the new
york times bombshell tax story
are there even more questions about
who trump owes money to where he got
outrageous amounts of cash that don't
seem to fit his financial situation
during that period 06 to 14. yeah
absolutely
even more questions about it which raise
even more national security questions in
terms of a trump who could be
could be manipulable or subject to
coercion because of the amount of money
that he owes yes
the second bottom line is is this going
to matter in terms of the 2020 election
i hate to say it particularly with more
time now having passed
since the sunday story i think the
answer is no
i i do not think at this point in time
that donald trump is going to be hurt in
any significant way by the new york
times bombshell tax story and what's
crazy about that is
for years we've been saying
the suspicion is trump pays
no or very little taxes trump's not as
wealthy as he thinks as he claims to be
trump owes a lot of people money it was
all proven true by the new york times
bombshell story
and yet the people who care are mostly
already not voting for donald trump
and the people who are voting for donald
trump aren't going to be influenced by
it either way so as much as it pains me
to say it because of what it says about
the american voting public at this point
and it says something very very
bad and sad i don't think that the tax
story is going to make a difference if
you disagree with me
i want to hear from you and again as far
as debates are concerned
vp debate on wednesday kamala harris
versus mike pence
i predict there will be uh fewer
interruptions from pence than what we
saw from donald trump
and i expect kamala harris is going to
absolutely hammer on mike pence i'm
actually looking forward to it
not in a car crash way but in an
actually
we might get some policy discussion sort
of way that'll be next wednesday
hope you'll join me on youtube twitch
and facebook one of our sponsors today
is monk pack keto granola bars
and they are giving you 20 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
snack and use the coupon code pacman
you know a lot of these low carb snack
bars
have a reputation for not tasting great
but
i can tell you from trying these myself
that that is not the case with the monk
pack
keto granola bars they taste just as
good
if not better than the sugar-filled
chewy granola bars that many of us
love but these contain only one gram of
sugar
two net carbs only 140 calories they're
completely plant-based and gluten-free
great for anybody following a low-carb
diet
but also perfect for anybody like me
who's just trying to
reduce sugar intake which i think is a
good thing i've been working
on a box of these at home they're
delicious soft chewy texture
bunch of great flavors including peanut
butter coconut cocoa chip which is my
personal favorite
it's great for a quick breakfast a snack
in the afternoon
i have been loving these you can get to
their website by going to
davidpakman.com
snack the link is under this video and
you'll get twenty percent off when you
use the coupon code
pacman